as one of the most seismic moments in
american history was unfolding the
president was in the most unlikely of
settings
moments before entering that florida
classroom he'd been told a small plane
had hit the first tower
the president the principal and i all
had the same reaction oh what a horrible
accident the pilot must have had a heart
attack or something for his chief of
staff
the picture soon changed captain lowe
came back up to me and said oh my god
another plane hit the other tower at the
world trade center
and i knew that this was not a
coincidence
it wasn't an accident
and so i decided to pass on two facts
and make one editorial comment to the
president and to do nothing to invite a
dialogue with them i thought about what
i would say i opened the door to the
room came in
that's when i walked up to the president
and i leaned over and i whispered into
his right ear a second plane
hit the second tower
america is under attack
and i looked at the president i could
still see him facing forward
with his head bobbing up and down
i honestly believe he was thinking about
the burden that he accepted when he took
the oath of office
i like to say that's when he became the
president
and i was very impressed that he did
nothing to introduce fear to those
second graders he did nothing to
demonstrate fear to the media that would
have satisfied the terrorists all around
the world
charity wallace was at the white house
i remember just this cacophony of sound
of people yelling and screaming and
running in the heels on that tile
and secret service were running and
that's really what scared me because i'd
never seen secret service run before and
as we were running towards the gate
the agent looked at all the women and
said take your shoes off and run for
your life and i
physically stopped because
it was such a jarring and terrifying
thing to hear and i just said
where are we supposed to go and he said
get as far away from here as you can
what would have seemed unthinkable 20
years ago now after the withdrawal from
afghanistan has become a reality
what's happened in afghanistan has just
made mrs bush really sad and sick
honestly for the women we've talked a
lot about that
um there they will be commemorating um
september 11th this 20th anniversary
and
i think that again they reflect
like i do on the courage and bravery on
the sacrifice of the men and women in
uniform and all of that i do think that
there is a sense that people have
forgotten
in a way
that day and everything that happened
that day
the fight for freedom
that united our country at the time
do you fear that there's a danger that
people forget
i've always felt that it was a slight
danger i think that it's been
exacerbated by what happened in
afghanistan over the last month i am
haunted by the images of 9 11 and i want
other people to feel the emotion out of
respect i remember september 11 2001
every day i feel more convicted to make
sure young people understand what
happened
so
it's for me it's not 20 years ago for me
it's yesterday
a moment in history this weekend they
will remember greg milam sky news new
york